we have five pieces of advice that we
want to give as part of the vaccine
response against this new variant
the first
we're advising that the booster program
should now be extended to adults age 18
to 39 years old
this is in addition to the existing
program for boosters meaning that from
now
all adults aged 18 years and above would
be eligible for a booster
the second
piece of advice is that the booster
program should follow prioritization
according to age and being in a risk
group in other words somebody with an
underlying health condition that puts
them at higher risk of covet 19.
the reason for this is that we have not
seen any data to suggest a new variant
is in any way different from the
previous variants in terms of who is
most at risk of severe disease
as we know from before
older age persons and people with
underlying health conditions are at
higher risk of severe disease and so we
want to protect them as a priority
the booster program is therefore
prioritized now according to age
with the boosted dose given no sooner
than three months after the second dose
the third
piece of advice is that people who are
severely immunocompromised should also
now be offered a booster dose
for them this would be their fourth
vaccine dose
the first three doses they've received
so far counts as their primary cause and
the booster dose will be their fourth
dose
once again the boosted dose should be
given no sooner than three months after
their last vaccine dose or the third
dose
fourthly
regardless of the type of vaccine that
was given for the primary cause the
first two doses
either of the mrna vaccines that is the
moderna vaccine or the pfizer beyond
type vaccine
can and should be used in preference as
the booster vaccine
the moderna vaccine at 50 micrograms
which is half the dose used in the
primary cause
and divisor beyond vaccine at 30
micrograms standard adult dose both give
extremely good antibody levels they
generate a very strong immune response
given as a boost
there are some people who are unable to
receive an mrna vaccine and they may
have had the estrogenical vaccine
both for their first dose and their
second doses
for them
we advise that they receive as their
booster the astrazeneca vaccine again
the estrogenical vaccine does give a
good boost albeit not as good as
the moderna and fisa beyond vaccines but
it's still a good boost and we would
advise that they have a boost rather
than have no booster dose at all
lastly
we advise that children age 15 sorry 12
to 15 years are offered a second dose of
vaccine at the standard dose of 30
micrograms of fisa beyond vaccine
12 weeks after their first dose
this is the same schedule as for 16 and
17 euros at the moment
we are closely watching the emerging
data on omicron
and if there is a need to
advise that the dose interval between
those one and those two four children
should be altered then we will do so
at the moment the dose interval between
those one and those two for 12 to 15
euros and 16 and 17 euros is 12 weeks
overall the priority
is the booster program
particularly for older adults and those
with underlying health conditions that
put them at higher risk from covet 19.
the majority of people who are aged 50
years and above
are already eligible for a booster
some
of those who are already eligible have
not yet received their booster
vaccination
i strongly urge everyone who is already
eligible to please make the effort
book your appointment and have the
booster that will be the best way to
protect yourselves your loved ones and
the wider society against any possible
new variant wave of infection
thank you
thank you very soon so um before we open
for questions i'd just like to kind of
sum up a little bit
today we've heard
some very reassuring words from uh dr
rain about the safety of the booster
program as it is
monitored in an ongoing way
and i think the three
key themes
we've heard in relation to
omicron and the jcv advice
are
uncertainty concern
and timing
an opportunity now to get the timing
right
jcvi has today announced renewed urgency
and further expansion of the uk booster
programme
we don't know what's going to happen
next as i explained to you the next
three weeks are going to be weeks of
scientific uncertainty
but whilst we wait for the mist to clear
on what this concerning variant actually
means
there is no time to delay it's our
opportunity to get ahead
and vaccine boosting
is the thing we can do most easily
whilst we wait for that science mist to
clear
so to me and as you know i love football
we started with 11 players in the team
with the wuhan vaccine and you could say
that we've kind of picked up a couple of
injuries when alpha came along and then
delta came along
those variants that are slightly
different from the wuhan
original strain
and
we've had to use our subs off the bench
to keep us in the game but we're well in
the game and you can see that with the
current epidemiology in relation to
delta that the vaccines are holding up
very well and largely keeping us out of
trouble
now omicron
is like now picking up a couple of
yellow cards to key players on top
we may be okay but we kind of starting
to feel at risk that we might go down to
10 10 players
and if that happens or if that's a risk
that it's going to happen then we need
everyone on the pitch to up their game
in the meantime and that's really upping
your game in terms of boosters and in
terms of antibody responses we're not
going to wait for the red card to happen
we're going to act decisively now
and we're asking everyone to up their
game
we're asking everyone to play their part
in
the urgency now of the booster program
coming forward the moment you are called
by the nhs
it's really frankly never been more
vital that
the booster campaign has never been more
vital than at this point in time